welcome back Ukraine's President
Vladimir zelensky is Accused Russian
troops of putting objects resembling
explosives at the zaparitia nuclear
power plant officials have issued
guidance to ukrainians about how to
leave a radiation Zone in the case of a
nuclear accident meanwhile Russia claims
it's ukrainians who are preparing to
attack the plant president zielinski had
this to say last night
now we have information from our
intelligence that the Russian troops
have placed objects resembling
explosives on the roof of several power
units that the zaparesia nuclear power
plant
s to simulate an attack on the plant
perhaps they have some other scenario
but in any case the world sees can't but
see that the only source of danger to
the zaparisian nuclear power plant is
Russia and no one else
Russia
well I'm joined to Now by our defense
and security analyst that Professor
Michael Clark Michael great to see you
as always so just update us what's
happened in the last the last 24 hours
in and around the power plant well quite
a lot the fifth of July has always been
quite a big date for a few weeks now the
Russians have been saying that they
wanted to withdraw people from the plant
by the 5th of July that's the Ukrainian
civilians who work at the plant the
technicians as well as some of their
forces and quite a lot has been seen
happening
um the ukrainians have been saying for
some time that they've seen explosives
being taken to the plant and placed
there I mean there's been some
explosives there since last August and
the ukrainians are now saying that that
numbers three and four you know there
they are numbers three and four counting
from the left to the right one two three
four those middle two have been uh
placed with explosions at the top at the
top of the reactors and that's very
interesting because anyone trying to
blow a reactor up will blow it up from
the bottom but if you explode something
from the top that almost certainly is to
make it look as if it's incoming
artillery rounds that would do it if
that's true that's what's being said and
so and last night or now about uh uh 27
28 hours ago
um Power to numbers three and four was
cut off so numbers one two five and six
are still on Main grid but three and
four have been taken off the grid and I
put on auxiliary auxiliary power only
now that suggests something's going to
happen to numbers three and four the
Russians have been saying for a long
time and Russian telegram channels are
alive with chat in the last day that the
ukrainians are planning to to attack the
plan that's ridiculous but it's what
they're saying so the whole thing looks
as it's building up at least to the the
edge of a false flag operation of a
major uh nuclear accident so so two
questions there How likely therefore it
sounds like likely best when we just
said is some form of explosion on
numbers three and four and How likely is
it that it's a truly damaging nuclear uh
disaster versus something that's just
meant to scare people second question
first
um if it happens then it will be some
something akin to Chernobyl of 1986
because although these these these
plants are all powered down then they're
not working they still have fuel rods in
them the rods have got to be kept cool
and if they if they're exploded with the
exposes on the top exactly exactly it
would still cause damage and they will
probably overheat even even in their
passive State and so there will be some
nuclear fallout and then it depends on
which way the wind is blowing you might
blow over Russia but equally it might
blow over the west Western Europe now
will they do it well there's been a
there's been a a campaign going for a
long time now that the Russians have
been talking about this and what they're
saying is if if the ukrainians attack us
and ukrainians certainly are pushing
from zapparagias Ukraine's own
zapparesia the city but zaprasia power
plant is the other side of the river a
little Way South and the Russians have
got that and they're saying if the
ukrainians attack us and remember
Ukraine has had a news blackout now on
across up Asia so something is happening
if they attack us then they they will
probably shell the plan the Russians
have been saying that for a long time so
they want to frighten everybody and they
have reached the point now of Maximum
fear but are they mad enough to do it
yes they are so so interestingly because
following on for what we were discussing
yesterday as well are we seeing from the
Ukrainian perspective that attacking or
counter-attacking is a lot harder than
defending or at least there are a lot of
things that the Russians can be doing
that at least distracts attention and
makes you think well it's better to sit
tight because what's on offer here
what's being threatened is is so
damaging absolutely yeah I mean
Defenders always have an easier time
than attackers generally speaking
attackers have to have generally three
times the amount of force of the
Defenders if the Defenders behave
normally and and so you've got to
concentrate forces at the point of
impact so you've got to have an
advantage in the impact point but
equally The Defenders can do lots of
things the Russians are doing I mean
they blew the uh novocovka Dam that
created an environmental catastrophe and
change the shape of the battlefield
they've built another Dam near
um top Mac and they're they're flooding
the fields to the east of top Mac and
they will blow that down that they've
created to flood top Mac if they need to
and this is the sort of thing that
Defenders will do if they're desperate
it's a scorched Earth policy and the
Russians of course you know they believe
in scorched Earth policies they do it
everywhere else in the world that
they've operated Michael as ever
fascinating thanks so much